So, jetzt sollte es gehen.
Oh, ich habe auch keinen Bock mehr. Die Stimmung ist am Tiefpunkt. Leute, wir sind ACDC, wir haben uns aber schon zwei Stunden Soundtest gemacht, wir haben keinen Bock mehr. Können wir nicht ... Ich kann Highway to Hell auch nicht mehr hören. Hat jemand eine Frage ... Die ganze Zeit ... Was, wer hört sich das überhaupt noch an? Hat jemand eine Frage aus dem Publikum? Duhm, ich würde mal fragen, wie seid ihr auf euren Hit Highway to Hell gekommen? Gott, was soll ich denn darauf antworten, wie seid ihr darauf gekommen? Wie bist du darauf gekommen, die Tür dir auszusuchen im Baumarkt, was soll das sein, was soll man da fragen, ich bin Genie, ich bin Musikalische Genie, die Dinge fliegen mir zu, die Muse hat mich geküsst, ich habe es in meinem Inneren gespürt, das sind meine Gefühle und meine Emotionen. Halt deinen Mund, du fettes Schwein. Wie bist du darauf gekommen, so fett zu werden? Wie bist du darauf gekommen, dir noch einen schönen Snickers reinzuschieben, obwohl du eh schon drei gegessen hast heute? Wie bist du darauf gekommen? Was hat dich dazu inspiriert? Ich habe eine Züste in meiner Schilddrüse. Komm, tschüss, geht nach Hause. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, du bist in einem Fall, du bist das kein Lied, das ist kein Song. Das ist nicht Highway to Hell. Das ist niemanden Song, was du singst. Ich habe mir damals bei der Band, ich habe auch mal irgendwann angefangen, so Lieder zu schreiben, wo ich mir ganz oft dachte, ich habe ganz oft den Prozess abgebrochen mit, ne, das ist kein Lied. Ich dachte, du gehst in die Anregung und sagst, wie immer sowas. Die, we, we, we, sowas. Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne. Das ist geil. Thorsten, komm mal kurz her. Das habe ich auch oft gemacht, dass einfach eins zu eins irgendwelche Green Day Songs, damit es nicht einfach Binky Sack-Boo Songs mit deutschem Text, also Green Day Songs mit deutschem Text waren. Naja, folg mal ein Intro ab. Oh, okay. Oh, stimmt, habe ich viel vergessen. Nee, eigentlich muss das Intro, kam schon. Nee, das kam doch nicht. Okay. Ich habe noch keines gehört. Ja, weil das erst im Nachhinein, wie, das wird erst, wie es So, heute vielen Dank an unseren fantastischen Hörer Sören, der uns dieses Intro geschickt hat. Viel Spaß mit dem Intro, das habt ihr am Anfang schon mal gehört. Nee, es kommt jetzt noch mal. Jetzt hört ihr es noch mal. Viel Spaß mit Sören. Auf liest es gut. Danke, Sören.
Ach so, ich dachte, jetzt kommt dann dieser Transbeat, der immer kommt bei allen den Führer-Vorschlägen. Und ich mache auch immer Frage, weil man muss ja sagen, dass oft die Musik einer Serie zum Beispiel, die Titelmusik, oft ja irgendwie die Atmosphäre capturiert. und dann irgendwie
dann sozusagen
die Inhalte der Serie auswringt, auspresst
und am Ende kommt so dieser Saft, dieser Reihenmusik raus. Und weil der Intro-Song von True Detective nimmt ja die Stimmung wunderbar auf. Von Westworld auch. Ja, aber gut ausgewählt. Und bei uns werden die Hörerintros, die bei uns immer kommen, da denke ich mir, so nehmt ihr uns wahr, ein aufgekratzter Trance-Dance-Floor, wo offensichtlich alle auf Ecstasy sind. Ja, wir hatten bis jetzt viel elektronische Musik, was interessant ist, weil wir, glaube ich, beide Konnoisseure der akustischen Musik sind. Also ich finde, hartes Holz muss auf der Bühne präsent sein, sonst kommt ja gar nicht erst hin. Aber es ist nur Drum'n'Bass. Es ist ausschließlich Drum'n'Bass. Es gab mal so eine Drum'n'Bass-Phase, wo alles Drum'n'Bass war, wo jeder Radio-Jingle Drum'n'Bass war. Dann gab es eine Phase, und ich bin so froh, dass wir die hinter uns haben, Elektroswing. Alter, ich hasse Elektroswing. Warum? Dubstep war eine Phase, wo ich dachte, jetzt reicht es aber. Ja, aber Dubstep war als ... Ja, aber Dubstep war, selbst als es populär war, war es schon ein Gag. Dubstep war immer ein Gag. Dubstep hat so diese ... Es gibt ja immer so die Phase und dann gibt's die Ironiephase, wo das, was vorher war, noch mal ironisch ... Du meinst, Dubstep war immer ironisch. Dubstep hat direkt ironisch angefangen. Dubstep war immer schon irgendwie schon lächerlich. Aber man hat so direkt als, ah, ist das kultig abgefallen. Ich glaub, wie Del Rey auch immer, ich glaube, die hat auch sofort so lächerlich angefangen. Lächerlich, traurig. Lana Del Rey? Ich muss immer lachen, wie traurig die ist. So viel Traurigkeit kann in dem Menschen doch gar nicht sein. So viel Depression und Herzschmerz riss doch nicht in so ein kleines Ding rein. Ich würde sagen, die ist eher melancholisch. Es ist eher so was ruhiges Menschen hat, aber so aber so wirklich nicht so mir geht's schlecht, Freund. Ich mag nicht! Nee, aber so ist sie doch ein bisschen. Nee, komm jetzt! Die ist so eine Weltvergessenheit, so eine gewisse Leere am Horizont, so ein leerer Blick in so einen Tannenwald. Wenn man sie hier kommt, sagt sie, ja, zieh erstmal die Schuhe aus, komm rein, sorry, ich hab mich nicht durchgewischt, weil ich die ganze Woche war wieder, hat auch noch Joe Schluss gemacht. Was ist das für eine Scheisse hier gegen Lana Del Rey? War traurig, Schaden eigentlich. Wie lustig wär's denn, wenn du wirklich in Alben lang deine ganzen Emotionen ausschüttest, traurige Musik machst und dann auf ein Konzert von dir gehst, wo du dann ein Konzert gibst und merkst, alle haben es ironisch wahrgenommen und alle lachen die ganze Zeit
und auch lachen, es hat Gags verstehen, die Songs.
Ich finde, Lana Del Rey ist die amerikanische
Lena Meyer-Landrut und deswegen ist sie
schon außerhalb jeder Kritik. Aber ist Björk nicht schon
die Amerikanerin?
Ich weiß es nicht. Die mit dem Schwan?
Komm, jetzt
wir sind schon in Klatsch und Tratsch, jetzt hau deine Klatsch-Boulevard-Story raus, die du unbedingt erzählen wolltest. Ich muss unbedingt erzählen, Pete Davidson, von dem wir grosser Fan sind. Comedian. Comedian und SNL-Cast-Member. Das jüngste SNL-Cast-Member aller Zeiten. So, und der war lange mit der Tochter von Larry David zusammen, Cassie David, die wir auch schon oft empfohlen haben, weil die diese ganz tolle Webserie, kann man nochmal empfehlen, 86th hat. Wie schreibt man das? 86th. Du kannst auch wie die Zahl schreiben, da kommst du auch drauf. Also 86th. Ja, 6th. Und das macht mich total, die waren zusammen. Und jetzt hört man, man munkelt dann, sie ist immer in Richtung Afrika unterwegs gewesen, sah man auf ihrem Instagram-Channel. Und dann habe ich durch unsere lieben Freundin Katjana Gerz erfahren, hast du das Neues mitbekommen? Ich dachte, was? Ja, Cassie David und Pete Davidson sind nicht mehr zusammen. So, und dann war der Tag für mich gegessen. Der war gelaufen. Weil du von Bayern-Fan hast. Ich habe meinen Tag freigenommen, erst einmal, weil ich damit nicht klarkam. Hast du eine Reihe gehört? Eine Reihe gehört und mit so einem grossen Bergerys Eisbecher gegessen. Nur den Becher. Nur den Becher, das Eis habe ich eingefroren. Und das war wirklich, das ist ganz, ganz schlimm für mich, weil die beiden waren so ein Traumpaar. Beide waren lustig, ich hätte mich mit ihm identifizieren können, auf eine Art so connecten können, auf so eine jemand kommt jung in eine Welt, die er nicht versteht, in Business, was schon existiert. Bisschen zu gross auch? Bisschen zu gross. Er hat Asthma, du hast eine komische Brust. Nee, da konnte ich mich nicht mehr mit ihm, also ich bin kein Gesund, da war ein bisschen anders. Aber ich konnte mich sehr mit ihm identifizieren und dann hat er aber halt diese wunderbare Freundin. Und dadurch, dass er die jetzt verloren hat, denke ich mir, gut, ich bin für mein Leben lang verloren.
Alle Frauen, die mir was bedeuten werden, werden mit mir Schluss machen, immer. Moment, also du hast dich in allen Aspekten mit ihm identifiziert, aber den Bonus, oh, hübsche Freundin, hast du dir sozusagen auch gewünscht, aber bist du nicht jetzt eigentlich wieder näher an ihm dran?
Na gut, aber jetzt, für mich ist jetzt so, angenommen, ich bekomme mal irgendwann die perfekte Freundin, weil es in meinem Bild ja, ich könnte mich auch mit ihr identifizieren zum Stück weit. Aber in dem Moment, wo sie sich trennen und er mit Ariana Grande zusammenkommt, habe ich alles, jeder denkt, jede Defektionspotenzial, hat sich in Luft aufgelöst. Weil, also auch egal, wie cool du dich hältst, Ariana Grande ist ein Stück drüber für dich. So, und dann denke ich mir, wie fühlt sie sich denn jetzt so? Sie kennt man ja sie kennt man ja nicht, ihr Channel ist weniger erfolgreich als gute Arbeit Originals, wo ich mir denke, du hast einen Freund und dann macht er mit dir Schluss, um mit Ariana Grande zusammenzukommen? Das ist schon alles... Das gibt's doch überhaupt nicht. Wie fühlst du dich denn dann? Und Katjana, ich hab wirklich acht Stunden mit ihr diskutiert, war der Meinung, sie fühlt sich jetzt sehr schlecht. Und dann hat sie gesagt, man fühlt sich auch immer schlecht, wenn die neuen Freunde des Ex-Freundes, die neue Freundin des Ex-Freundes hübscher ist als du. Du willst, dass die neue Freundin deines Ex-Freundes hässlicher ist. Ich kann das nicht nachvollziehen, weil du dann, du bist ja in einer Liga, sagen wir mal, ich bin der Typ von ihr, wenn sie jetzt mit einem wesentlich hübscheren Bodybuilder zusammenkommt, denke ich mir auch, ja gut, das ist doch gut für mich jetzt, weil ich ja in einer Liga bin mit diesem sehr attraktiven Freund. Ja, es ist halt nachvollziehbar. Die Frage ist, also wenn du sagst, okay, dein neuer Freund ist hübscher als ich, ergibt Sinn, tut weh, beneidisch, aber es ist verständlich. Ja, aber wenn der neue ... Nimm sie! Ja, ja, aber ich meine, was würde denn das Aussagen über dich, wenn die neue Freundin hässlicher ist als du? Weil dann sagst du, ja Moment, ich sehe besser aus, dann muss aber irgendwas anderes so viel schlechter sein. Das ist ja noch schlimmer eigentlich dann. Stell dir mal vor, der neue Freund meiner Ex-Freundin sitzt im Rollstuhl und ist blind. Da würde ich mir auch denken, ja... Sieht aber sehr gut aus.
So, nach Katernas Rechnung wäre ich
jetzt glücklicher. Ich würde mich echt
beschissen fühlen, um ehrlich zu sein.
Naja. Wenn nicht gerade Ariana Grande
im Rollstuhl blind.
Okay, jetzt wird's kompliziert.
Jetzt wird's komplex. Die neue lesbische Freundin
meiner Ex-Freundin wäre,
da wäre ich... Das ist schon...
Ich fand das sehr schwierig. Und für mich war das sehr schwierig zu verstehen, diese ganze Sache, vor allem, wir sind echt so ein Glas und Tratsch, die bunte der Podcast sind wir jetzt, ja vor allem, und dann kam die, da hatte sie direkt ein paar Tattoo von ihm, wo ich mir auch dachte, muss das denn jetzt sofort sein, ja, ich meine, es ist, es ist Ariana Grande, es ist die beste Ariana, ich meine, das ist nicht so Ariana Medium, so, es ist Es ist Ariana Grande. Also ich meine, das ist die krasseste, die es gibt. Aber ich meine, die muss ja schon ein bisschen, also ich meine, du kannst ja nicht mit ihm Schluss machen und am nächsten Tag bist du mit Ariana Grande zusammen. Und die Ex-Freundin hat davon noch nie was gehört. Du kriegst ja mit, wenn dein Freund wo, wo, du kennst wem? Das war schon eigentlich das
erste, da für mich fing das ganze
Unheil an. Oh, wo, wo, du kennst
wem? Ja, vor allem diese unangenehme Situation,
wo er dann noch sein ganzes Zeug aus ihrer Wohnung
holt und die Neue ist mit dabei und
die Tür geht auf, da steht Ariana Grande
und so. Und du willst erst mal ein Foto machen.
Sorry, ist alles cool zwischen uns und du so,
kann ich ein Foto?
Man will sauer sein, aber auch ein Foto. Das ist immer, ich kann es verstehen. Ich kann, also die haben sich ja wahrscheinlich bei SNL kennengelernt, oder? Ariana Grande hat ja einen Auftritt, einen genialen Sketch, schaut ihn euch an, Ariana Grande SNL, die kann nicht nur unfassbar gut singen, sondern die kann unfassbar gut Gesangsimitation machen. Die kann so singen
wie Britney Spears, wo selbst Britney
Spears sich denkt, ja, was soll der Scheiß
jetzt? Ich meine,
die kann besser singen
als ich, als ich.
Ich meine, das ist wie,
was soll das denn für ein Scheiß?
Also unfassbar talentierte junge Frau.
Ob das der Sketch war, wo Pete Davidson sagte,
wow, ciao Cassie.
Pete Davidson denkt sich, ich bin ja nicht nur mit Ariana Grande
zusammen, sondern auch mit Shakira
Aber unfassbar talentierte junge Frau. Ob das der Sketch war, wo Pete Davidson sagte? Wow. Ciao, Cassie. Pete Davidson denkt sich, ich bin ja nicht nur mit Ariana Grande zusammen, sondern auch mit Shakira, Beyonce, Britney Spears, mit allen Popstars der Welt. Krass. Ja, ich kann es irgendwo verstehen. Naja, das war der bunte Podcast. Ciao. Und dann vor allem, Follow-up von letzter Folge, direkt Partner-Tattoo. Stimmt richtig. Und du hast eine Nachricht geschrieben, wie schaut es denn aus, alle seit einer Woche sitzen sie, Fingernägel kauen vor ihren Empfangsgeräten, hat WC-Ente geantwortet. Oh, jetzt schon? Ich dachte, das ist das große Finale der Folge. Naja, wenn wir gerade bei fiesen Nachrichten sind, wollte ich das mal rausleiern. Tatsächlich, Stefan und ich haben, glaube ich, die Woche keine einzige Silbe miteinander kommuniziert. Wir haben lediglich das Datum für die Aufnahme kommuniziert, ansonsten gar nichts. Ich weiß nichts, was los ist. Ich habe tatsächlich keine Ahnung selber, ob wir eine Antwort bekommen haben oder nicht, was da drin stand. Das heißt, die Einmoderation hätten aus nichts laufen können. Es ist eine maschinelle Antwort, es ist eine enttäuschende Antwort, es ist eine fritzige Antwort. Ich bin sehr, sehr gespannt. Meine Damen und Herren, das hier ist die WC-Ente, Teil zwei. S.C. Johnson & Son. Das ist die Firma, ne? Incorporate. Schreibt uns. Sehr geehrter Herr Tietze. Vielleicht steht es eher für Incompetent. Ja. What? Was schreiben Sie? Sehr geehrter Herr Tietze, vielen Dank für Ihrem E-Mail. Gerne bearbeiten wir Ihr Anliegen. Okay, das ist, naja. Für uns ist die WC-Ente eine klassische Ente mit Schnabel. Für weitere Fragen stehen wir gern zur Verfügung. Bevor ich begrüße, Markus. Das ist die Antwort. Du kannst dir einfach sagen, für uns ist es eine Ente. Für uns ist die WCEnte eine klassische Ente im Schabel. Das liest sich auch so ein bisschen passiv-aggressiv. Du kannst nicht einfach sagen, für uns ist das eine Ente. Das geht nicht, das ist nicht subjektiv, was eine Ente ist und was nicht. Ich sehe ja tatsächlich in der Antwort, wie meine, also ich habe ja nicht in der Mail geschrieben, der klassischen, sondern über dieses Antwortformular, über deren Seite. Und ich habe ja diese wütende Mail geschrieben, muss man sagen, haben wir zusammen. Und jetzt sieht man hier, wie das formatiert wurde, und es ist wirklich, es sieht aus wie eine HTML-geschriebene Hassbrief, und deswegen kann ich es ein bisschen verstehen, dass es ein bisschen passiv-aggressiv so durchkommt. Für uns ist die BC-Ente eine klassische Ente mit Schnabel. Für weitere Fragen stelle ich Ihnen etwas vor. Eine klassische Ente. Er schreibt, für weitere Fragen stehen wir Ihnen gern zur Verfügung. Tut er nicht. Eine klassische Ente mit Schnabel. Ist eine klassische Ente. Ist eine klassische Ente mit Schnabel. Aber haben die mal eine Ente gesehen? Aber jetzt hat uns ein Hörer darauf aufmerksam gemacht, dass ein Schwan ein Entenvogel ist. Für mich war der Begriff Entenvogel. Jetzt haben wir richtig scheiße gebaut. Für mich war der Begriff, wollen wir uns entschuldigen? Also ein zweites Mal in der Geschichte des Podcast-Ufos müssen wir uns bei den Enten entschuldigen. Es tut uns wirklich sehr leid. Irgendwie sind wir auf dem falschen Fuss mit euch aufgestanden. Ja, irgendwie funktioniert es nicht richtig. Sorry nochmal. Sorry. Ja, es war nicht unser Anliegen. Wir haben einfach zu schnell gehandelt, zu wenig gedacht. Und ihr verdient das nicht, ihr seid toll. Wir nehmen es zurück. Wir fassen zusammen. Schwäne gehören zu euch, sind Entenvögel. Man darf Enten auf gar keinen Fall mit Nudeln füttern. Und auf gar keinen Fall mit Brot. Fütter generell Enten einfach nicht. Lass es. Vielleicht mit Gummibärchen. Aber da will ich mich aus dem Fenster lehnen. Einmal probieren wir es noch. Vielleicht sind es Gummibärchen. Aber wie fies das ist, dass Schwäne Entenvögel sind, aber Enten keine Schwänevögel. Was ist das für eine weirde Hierarchie? Warum ist Ente überhaupt in der Hierarchie grösser? Warum ist Ente eine Gattung? Wann die Ente vorm Schwan entdeckt? Was war das erste Tier, das entdeckt wurde? Es gab ja einen Zeitraum, wo Menschen dachten, die sind alleine auf der Welt. Und dann kam irgendwann so ein Dachs und die Menschen dachten, what the fuck? Was ist denn mit dem los? Dann stellt sich raus, es ist ein Säbelzahntiger. Und dann war erst mal die Kacke am Dampfen. Was war das erste Tier, mit dem Menschen in Kontakt gekommen? Ich glaube, Säbelzahntiger. Ja, ist straight direkt tot. Direkt tot. Mammut, Säbelzahntiger und Mammut, sorry. Beides sieht aus wie ein modernes Tier, aber gefährlicher. Ein Upgrade, eine Upgrade-Stufe. Warum? Mammuts haben stärkere Stosszähne. Größere, stärkere Stosszähne. Und mehr Fell. Vor allem Elefanten haben ja gar kein Fell. Ist das ein bisschen übertrieben? Ich dachte jetzt, dass sie eher so runtergehen auf so Stoppel, wie so ein Schwein. Aber haben nicht so Borsten. Elefanten haben gar nichts. Haben keine Borsten. Elefanten sind splitternackt, sind straight full frontal nudity. Wenn die diese Blush-Partikel, wenn man so rot anläuft, wenn die das hätten, glaube ich, dann wären sie die ganze Zeit so ein bisschen peinlich berührt. Können noch andere Sachen als Menschen erröten eigentlich? Erröten andere Tiere auch? Rotkehlchen? Rotkehlchen ist die ganze Zeit. Der Rotkehlchen ist die ganze Zeit. Kann ich hier sein? Oder ist es schon? Aaaaaah!? Kommt er mich an? Ich bin in diesen Garten geflogen und ich weiß nicht, ob hier sein kann. Ist das ein Pool? Kann ich hier gar nicht? Ich habe eine traumatische Erfahrung mit einem Rotkehlchen gemacht. Stell sich heraus, war keine Rotkehlchen, sondern ein Eisvogel. Dein Onkel. War ein Eisvogel. Was ist ein Eisvogel? Du meinst ein Eis? Nee, ein Eisvogel. Aus der Familie der Entenvögel. Eisbär-Eisvogel. Jedenfalls hatten wir so einen großen Teich und dann habe ich diesen Eisvogel beobachtet und dachte mir, wow, das ist ein kleiner, süßer Vogel, so einen kleinen, größeren Schnabel. Und dann habe ich den gesehen und der ist einfach im Sturz zurück in den Teich und hat einen halben Meter langen Fisch daraus geholt und ist weggeflogen. Und ich sass schreiend am Fenster, weil ich da das kann nicht gerade, ich kann nicht Tiere beim Sterben zugucken. Das war wirklich dramatisch. Ich habe wirklich nicht den Hauch einer Ahnung, was ein Eisvogel ist. Ein blauer Vogel, schöner Vogel, sehr selten. Das war so ein Vogel, wenn man dem Biolehrer erzählt hat, dass man den im Garten hatte, dann hat der Biolehrer so leicht nervös geworden. Aber der kann durchs Eis durch, oder was? Oder warum ist der Eisvogel? Der heisst Eisvogel, weil er die ganze Zeit, weiß ich nicht, Calipocola, denkt euch selber an Geck aus. Was ich meine, für Menschen gefriert der Boden zu, aber für Fische gefriert der Himmel zu. Nee, nicht in der Himmel. Es ist wirklich so andersrum. Ja, aber vor allem ist es problematisch, weil die keine Luft mehr bekommen. Weil ja auch die Luft quasi... Naja, pass auf. Ich ersticke, ich ersticke. Komm, halt die Fresse, bist ein fucking Fisch. Jedes Jahr den Gag. Ich glaube, wenn das passiert, nerven alle Stand-Up-Radio-Comedy bei Fischen und alle Stand-Up bei Fischen. Weil wieder nur wirklich einen Monat lang das gleiche Thema. Der Himmel ist zugefroren. Sie machen so eine Fake-Challenge so, wer kann am längsten die Luft anhalten, wir haben drei Fische im Studio und alle so, oh den Keck habt ihr letztes Jahr schon gemacht. Und jedes Jahr, jeder Fischsender zeigt Eilmeldung, Himmel schon wieder zugefroren. Und man denkt sich so, ja, macht's noch reiserischer. Es passiert nichts, wir haben das in den letzten acht Jahren überlebt. Warum glaubst du, es gibt so Fische, die schwimmen, also die Gegend und sehen dann plötzlich so einen anderen fisch und denken sich moment der bestimmt ja auf dem rücken und dann sehen sie noch anderen fischen so moment er fängt ach ich schwimme auf dem rücken fuck ich habe den ganzen morgen auf dem rücken geschwommen so du stehst auf und weil du hast ja keine orientierung du schwimmst einfach den ganzen morgen auf dem rücken ich glaube nicht dass dir hängt weil gerade wenn ich weiß wo ein boden ist wenn du so ein dunkler Fisch bist ganz Das ist ein Dunkelfisch bist, ganz tief. Unter Wasser gibt es doch keine Gravitation. Halt, du bist so komplett bescheuert. Hast du mal einen Stein fallen lassen im Wasser? Hat dir eigentlich jemanden ins Gehirn gehustet? Was ist denn los mit dir? Gehirn gehustet? Nicht ins Gehirn gehustet. Das war ein Stein, was im Wasser fallen. Fisch kann doch so mal so 30 Grad seitlich schwimmen und kriegst nicht mit. Ja, das ist eine Flunder. Die kriegen direkt Namen und werden abgestempelt als trottelige Fische. Übrigens einer der wenigen asymmetrischen Tiere. Ja, der Fisch kann doch locker. Wenn du als Fisch so 30 Prozent zur Seite geneigt schwimmst, kriegst du das nicht mit. Selbstverständlich ist das mit. Nein, wenn du so eine Koralle siehst am Boden und so, wups, okay. Du hast ja auch so eine Luftblase, die du aufblähen kannst als Fisch und dann kannst du aufsteigen. Und dannigst du nicht 30 Grad schräg auf, sondern weil es halt Gravitation, weil es Regeln gibt, ganz gerade hoch.
Das machst du die ersten zehn Tage, als Fisch danach Spaß hättest, dass du jeden Morgen eine Luftblase machst.
Das lernst du in der Fischschule, aber sobald du 18 bist, kommt.
So wie Vögel lernen müssen zu fliegen, müssen Fischer lernen zu schwimmen.
Gehen die erst auf den Boden und lernen dann erst, ah, Fisch. Das stimmt. Und dann fangen sieimmen. So mit so Schwimmflügeln. So mit so Schwimmflügeln. Eigentlich sind Fische schon das beste Tier, weil die können nicht ertrinken. Und die Wahrscheinlichkeit für einen Fisch, aus dem Wasser zu kommen, ist sehr gering. Zu verbrennen, auch sehr gering. Extrem gering. Ja, einzufrieren, sehr gross. Größer als bei sämtlichen anderen Tieren. Aber das Gefrieren ist doch super langsam. Du kannst immer wegschwimmen vom Eis. Es ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass auf einmal der ganze Fischsee eingefroren ist. Denn tatsächlich Austrocknung ist ein Thema. Also wenn so ein ganzer See austrocknet, dann hast du einfach verloren. Ja. Und dann gibt es so eine Krisensitzung. Ist das wiederum gut? Gibt es dann so eine Krisensitzung, so sollen wir versuchen, so 20 Meter nach Norden zu zappeln? Sollen wir es probieren? Es gibt ja tatsächlich eine berühmte Straße, weiß ich jetzt leider nicht mehr, wo Kanada vielleicht, nehmen wir aus dem Fenster. Sagen wir Kanada. Und dann haben die jedes Jahr so eine Flut und dann quasi bauen Lachse so eine Art Wasserbrücke über die Straße. Wie? Lachse. Wie tun die Wasser auf die Straße? Nee, durch die Flut kommt das eh automatisch so ein bisschen. Und dann zappeln die drüber, um dann auf der anderen Seite wieder ins Wasser zu springen. Können die gezielt zappeln? Gezielt zappeln. Also wirklich dann richtungsweise zappeln? Ja, GZZ. Oder zappeln die einfach nur und durch uns? Nein, die zappeln gezielt. Ganz gezielt. Nur leider ist es eine befahrene Straße. Und man kann schon ahnen, dass nicht viele das schaffen. Aber die Kerzen gerade gezielt gezappelt in eine Richtung. Und dann kommen sie im anderen Wasser an und dann so, ah, jetzt habe ich Füße bekommen. Ah, hier ist ein anderer pH-Wert. Ciao, tot. Wie, Alligator, tot. Aber kann ja passieren, wenn die Evolution zu schnell kommt, hast du Füße. Dann kommst du auf der anderen Seite an, hast Füße und denkst dir, ja, jetzt brauche ich keine Füße mehr. Aber das stimmt nicht, was wir gerade gesagt haben. Also gut, gut, die können stimmt es nicht, was wir gesagt haben. Wegen Podcast sind wir hier. Die können nicht erfrieren, nicht verbrennen, nicht ertrinken. Plus fünf Fisch, aber sobald der pH-Wert um 0,1 Prozent nach oben oder unten geht, sind die sofort tot. Lange Learnings aus dem Aquarium. Fucking pH-Wert. Fucking pH-Wert. Da weiss ich sogar ein bisschen was drüber.
Das eine ist Säure, das andere ist Alkalität und dann pendelt es dazwischen und am besten ist sieben.
Sieben ist neutral, glaube ich.
Kann man volle Flaschen als Pfand einreichen?
Definiere voll.
Ja, mit Inhalt, mit Getränke füllt.
Sich Zeit verschaffen. Stefan, Zeitsche nette. Definiere Faschen. Definieren Sie Völkermord. Okay. Kannst du Pfandflaschen in einem Satz benutzen? Ja, was ist eine Pfandflasche? Können Sie Vergewaltigung in einem Kontext benutzen, bitte? Können Sie es buchstabieren? Wo waren Sie zwischen sieben und acht Uhr? Können Sie... Was? Acht durch zwei. Nein, der ist weggelaufen! Das klappt jedes Mal! Fahren Sie den Taschenrechner wieder raus und hinterher! Oh, ey, sorry, ganz kurz für den Sound, ich hab keinen Popschutz. Puh, keinen Popschutz. Und die ganze Zeit hört ihr mein Atmen ... Du kannst auch übers Mikrofon drüber sprechen. Die ganze Zeit hört ihr noch, wie schwer ich noch atmen muss, weil ich heute morgen den Treppen hochgelaufen bin und will mittlerweile 19 Uhr haben, aber ich bin immer noch ein bisschen außer Atem, ich bin so außer Form. Ja, was ist los? Was ist aus Stefan Sporthitze geworden? Bist du immer noch in deinem Fitnessstudio? Ja, angemeldet, die haben mich ja wie gesagt abgezockt, jetzt bin ich nach drei Monaten angemeldet. Habe ich ja schon erzählt eigentlich, dass sie mir, dass sie den alten Betrag sprechen, obwohl die mittlerweile von einem billigen Konzern aufgekauft wurden? Ja, stimmt, ja. Und dann habe ich ja gefragt, warum ich denn eigentlich einen teureren Betrag bezahle. Ja, weil sie eine Kinderbetreuung und die Kaffeemaschine drin haben, haben sie dann gesagt. Wo ich mir dachte, Moment, Moment, das sind zwei Dinge, von denen ich niemals, niemals Kaffee im Fitnessstudio, das ist das Letzte, was ich brauche, wenn die abends um 22 Uhr im Fitnessstudio ankommen. Schönes Croissant, so ein Amaretto. Warum ist das Kaffee? Ich habe eine Kaffeemaschine im Preis ent und die Kinder. Welcher Mensch, was für eine Art Mensch bringt seine Kinder mit ins Fitnessstudio?
Aber darfst du dann zumindest ins Bettelbad?
Ja, gut, aber darfst du da dann... Ja gut, ich darf es nicht Bettelbad.
Das ist auch nicht schlecht.
Und die Rutsche.
Also Kinderbetreuung für mich oder für meine Kinder?
Oder wie läuft das?
Wie alt dürfen die Kinder sein?
Ja, aber das wollte ich ein bisschen übers Ohr gehauen.
Seitdem gehe ich da aus Wut auch nicht mehr hin. Auch weil die Frau am Telefon passt sich vor und ich habe Angst vor Konfrontationen. Und ja, seitdem habe ich keinen Sport mehr gemacht und deswegen bin ich ein bisschen außer Form. Ich finde, siehst toll aus. Dankeschön. Und ich meine, man muss es ja ansprechen, Stefan, wir wissen es alle, Stefan ist zu auf dem Boden geblieben und zu uneitel, dass er es selber anspricht. Aber ich muss es ansprechen, auch einfach, weil ich hier an der Stelle öffentlich... Auch einfach, weil ich jetzt so ein Schild hochhalte, dass es bitte ansprechen soll. Auch nochmal sagen möchte, Stefan Tietze, herzlichen Glückwunsch zum Studio Hamburg-Nachwuchspreis für bestes Entertainment. Also falls ihr euch denkt, Moment mal, was waren das jetzt gerade die letzten 23 Minuten? Das war das beste Entertainment der Welt. Nachwuchs, der Hamburgs. Hamburgs, und zwar verbrieft offiziell der Hamburger Studio-Preis, Studio Hamburg-Hamburg-Preis, an Stefan Titzlinghausen offiziell. Wo ist der Pott? Wo ist er? Ich habe ihn nicht mitgebracht, aber er ist wirklich, muss man, oh. So klingt es mir nicht einmal, die ganze Zeit. Das ist zu viel. Tatsächlich ist er sehr massiv, der Preis. Er ist so ein Stück Marmor. Ich weiß nicht genau, was Marmor ist, aber es ist einfach ein sehr, so ein massives Stück, so ein Nugget. So ein Nugget aus Stein. Marmor-Nugget. Und dann bin ich mit dem Flugzeug geflogen, zurück, dann wieder nach Köln. Und ich war sehr spät dran, muss man sagen, weil ich habe ein bisschen die Wartezeit beim Security-Check unterschätzt, beim Hamburger Flughafen. Und da stand ich schon sehr lange an und da war ich schon sehr nervös. Und dann zum Einfluss wurde mein Koffer auch noch raus, mein Handgepäckkoffer auch noch aus dem Verkehr gezogen. Und dann habe ich schon ein bisschen was geahnt. Da habe ich mich schon geahnt, in welche Richtung es gehen könnte. Und dann stand ich da, wie ich zehn Minuten, wenn ich die Abflugzeige kam, immer näher. Und dann kam der Satz durch den ganzen Security-Check gerufen, Entschuldigung, was haben Sie da in Ihrem Koffer? Was zum Teufel haben Sie da in Ihrem Koffer? Und dann habe ich gesagt, wie viel haben Sie mit dem Koffer? Und dann hat sie mir diesen Monitor zugeschoben, wo man dann dieses Bild sieht, wie durchleuchtet wird. Ja, aber geil. Und es war einfach das Schwärzeste, was jemals, und sie hat gesagt, ich kann nicht glauben, was sie da drin haben. Und da haben schon so vorsichtig die Polizeileute, die da rumstehen, so. Du hattest schon so einen Uzi-Lauf am Hals. Ja, ich hätte schon, wenn ich die AK-47 an der Schläfe. Und dann haben die das aufgemacht und haben durchwühlt. Und natürlich holen sie den Studio Hamburg-Nachwuchspreis hervor. Und der ganze Flughafen. Herzlich willkommen! Jetzt sind wir mit! Ja, und tatsächlich war es der Studio Hamburg-Nachwuchspreis. Und dann haben sie sich die fünf Minuten lang angeschaut, mussten dann selber ein bisschen grinsen. Und dann haben sie mich gehen lassen, ich habe den Flug so gerade noch bekommen, aber das war wirklich so eine Schrecksekunde, war eine Stolzsekunde und dann bin ich losgerannt zu meinem Geld und habe den Flug noch reinkommen.
Aber gut, wäre es gewesen, wenn Sie sagen, ja gut, wir wissen ja nicht, ob da drin nicht Sprengstoff ist. Kann ja jeder sagen. Bester Terrorist der Welt, einen Preis. Hol den Presslufthammer, Georg.
Und dann so, okay, kein Sprengstoff drüber, du kriegst einfach nur so Sand, einfach nur so Asche in deine Hand. Okay, herzlichen Glückwunsch. Aber Stefan, toll. Tolle Leistung. Wofür hast du das bekommen? Für deine Autorentätigkeiten? Autorentätigkeiten bei Krollmann und bei Gute Arbeit Originals. Geil. Und vielen Dank nochmal an dich, Florentin, für deine ganze Arbeit, für deine Unterstützung. Du hast mich von klein auf unterstützt. Gerne, ich hab dir einen Kaffee gebracht. Ich hab dich beraten, was man zum Mittagessen essen kann. Richtig. Und da fühle ich mich natürlich auch mitverantwortlich. Und du hast am Sketch mitgeschrieben. Ah ja. Und ich hab wirklich ja auch Geld bekommen für den Preis. Ach wirklich? Aber jetzt so richtig Cash, Cash, Cash oder so? Ja, schon Cash, Cash, Cash. Nein, wirklich? Cash, Cash. Aber das ist ja auch normal bei Nachwuchspreisen und bei Hamburg. Weil Nachwuchspreisen sind ja immer ein bisschen Geld, weil die ja Leute unterstützen wollen. Ach so. Die wissen ja nicht, dass ich schon steinreich bin. Ja, ursprünglich war es ja die Idee von so Sachen, dass man sich gerade Geld spart. Also Mittelalter zum Beispiel, wenn irgendein Ritter irgendwas für dich macht, du bist König und irgendein toller Ritter macht irgendwas für dich. Und dann ist die Frage, ja was kriegt der zu viel Land, kriegt der Pferd? Oder die Studie Hamburg-Nachwuchspreis. Er kriegt einen Orden, er kriegt halt also eine Ehrung. Ich verstehe. Ja, ich glaube, das ist aber auch steuerrechtliche Gründe bei denen. Ja, das kann man auch absetzen. Kann man absetzen, genau. Und dann kriegen die so einen Orden und dann sagt der Ritter so, ja danke, aber er hat eine Ehrung bekommen, deswegen gibt es tausende Orden. Ja, vor allem der Flug dahin war auch, also Fliegen ist toll, ich freue mich immer über Geschichten, die man danach erzählen kann, über das Fliegen. Und es war wirklich weird, ich bin in den Flieger gestiegen, hin nach Hamburg und ich war auch da wieder spät dran. Es zog sich immer ein bisschen durch den ganzen Trip durch, als wie so ein roter Faden. Du bist einfach schick, einfach, du lässt Leute auf dich warten, das kommt gut an. Ja, das kommt gut an, außer bei Leuten, die auf einen warten. Und dann tatsächlich bin ich eingestiegen in den Flieger und das hat sich schon ein bisschen hingezogen und dann tritt der Kapitän vor die Leute, nimmt sich dieses Stand-Up-Mikrofon und sagt dann, ja, durch das verzögerte Einsteigen haben wir jetzt unseren Slot verloren, unseren Abflugslot, wir können jetzt in drei Stunden fliegen. Hat auch so ein bisschen fauls vorgesagt, offensichtlich, weil die Leute ihm zu langsam eingestiegen sind. Ja. Und auch er los wollte. Und ich mich frage, warum wirst du da ankommen? Er war sehr sauer. Warum war er sehr sauer? Er ist der Pilot. Das ist sein Job. Aber ihr lasst ihn schlecht dastehen jetzt vor der Flugsicherung. Warum? Sein Job ist es, jetzt zu warten, einfach drei Stunden lang. Meine Reaktion wäre nicht, ja gut, das hat zu lange gedauert, jetzt können wir nicht losfliegen. Das wäre nicht meine Reaktion. Meine Reaktion wäre, ja, jetzt sind sie einfach zu lange, sind wir eingestiegen. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt drei Stunden lang Angry Birds spielen am Gate. Aber du bist Pilot, du hast ein Leben lang geübt, um zu fliegen. Du hast Bock auf Fliegen, deswegen bist du Pilot. Und du hast keinen Bock, drei Stunden auf der Bahn rumzufliegen.
Du meinst, Luft ist Comfortzone. Ja. Und am Gate stehen ist nervös. Der will in die Luft, der will los, der will schön die Flügel einklappen, der will raus da, raus in die Wolkenwelt. Und es ist ja so ein klassischer Arbeitslinienflug, wirklich nur mit Anzugträgern und alle hatten offensichtlich Einflusstermine. Weil das war so ein typischer Mitten-am-Tag-Flug, den man nur nimmt, wenn man abends noch was zu tun hat. Sonst nimmst du den späten Flug oder den Morgensflug. Aber es war ein typischer, ich hab dann Hamburg-Termin-Flug. Und ich hätte das noch nie erlebt, der ganze Flieger war von der einen Sekunde auf die andere unglaublich sauer. Aber wirklich der ganze Flieger gleichzeitig, was, unisono, das kann doch nicht wahr sein, gerufen. Und dann der Pilot, ja doch, das kann sein. Nein, kann es nicht, das können sie nicht machen, alle unisono, wie gesagt. Und das habe ich noch nie erlebt, es ist noch nie so viel Wut, ist gleichzeitig entwichen außen diesen Flieger beobachtet hat, ist es kurz so, der ist kurz breiter geworden, weil er so kurz so eine Welle aus Unmut. Der hat die Flügel so hängen lassen. Ja. Und der Blick, den Flugzeug ja so haben, so ein coole Blick, war kurz nicht mehr so cool. Ja, sauer. Ja, und dann kam es aber so, da war neben mir die Frau komplett aufgebracht, rechts neben mir der Mann auch komplett aufgebracht. Und dann hat die Frau dann zum Steward gesagt, ja, warum lassen Sie uns hier warten und nicht am Gate warten? Und dann kam die Stimme, oh, mittlerweile hat sich der Flug schon so ein bisschen nach vorne verschoben. Jetzt sind es irgendwie noch zwei Stunden fünfzig, alle immer noch extrem sauer. Und das wird ja aus diesem Grund, weil es einfach sehr schnell passieren kann, dass wir im Slot wieder nach vorne rutschen, weil auch nicht alle anderen Maschinen ihre Slots wahrnehmen. Zehn Sekunden danach kam die Meldung, okay, wir können jetzt doch in zehn Minuten fliegen. Und dann wiederum habe ich es auch noch nie erlebt, dass die ganze Wut, die sich angestaut hat in den Leuten, wo sollte die jetzt hin? Weil plötzlich war diese Wut, okay, man kommt zu spät, man hat schon die wütenden SMS geschrieben, alle hatten schon ihr Handy draus, haben schon telefoniert, waren noch im Schrei-Modus und dann kommt die Meldung, wir können jetzt in zehn Minuten in der Luft sein. Also quasi fast exakt so wie angekündigt. Und dann war so eine Situation aus Unwissen, Verwirrtheit. Man wusste nicht, wohin mit der ganzen Wut. Und dann ist einfach aus Köln nach Hamburg ein sehr, sehr, sehr saurer Flieger abgehoben. Unnötig sauer. Der nicht genau wusste, warum er sauer war. Und alle waren so Grund... Es war so eine ganz komische Stimmung in diesem Flieger, weil da kam dann auch immer... Die Wut kam nicht mehr raus. Die hätten dann so einen Boxack rumgegeben müssen, um wieder mal draufschlagen können, aber das hat man ja dann nicht. Ich glaube, das ist das Schlimmste, so aufgestaute Wut. Ich kann mir so vorstellen, dass dann... Man ist nicht gewohnt, die sofort wieder loslassen zu können. Ja, genau, dass dann irgendwie der Flieger komplett geladen ist und die Stewardess dann so, wir haben leider keinen Tomatensaft mehr.
Was? Und einfach dann mal nur darauf wartet als Ventil, dass es irgendwie rausgeht.
Und man nimmt den Nebenmann und bricht ihm das Genick.
Straight, stell dir vor, der Flug wäre abgestürzt.
Da wäre Getöse gewesen.
Weil da hätte ich alle Bock drauf gehabt.
Das geschieht euch recht. So, das ist ja mal wieder
typisch deutsche Bahn, wir stürzen ab,
da steht das Flugzeug in Flammen. Na, Dankeschön! Typisch Ryanair! Und meine Gasmaske geht nicht. Danke! Das ist, glaube ich, jetzt so ein bisschen, Stefan und ich, wir entwickeln uns ja anders schnell. Also Stefan ist auf der Überholspur, ihr merkt schon, irgendwie Studie Hamburg, Preis, irgendwie große Projekte, irgendwie Gala, Messen geht weit. Bei mir ist es einfach lockerer ein bisschen. Und Stefan Tietze ist einfach auf einer anderen Sphäre. Und ich glaube, das spiegelt sich auch in unseren Anekdoten wieder. Stefan Tietze mit den, ja, ich bin mit den Businessleuten da im Flieger stecken geblieben. Zehn Minuten Verspätung, typisch. Ich habe eine klassische ICE-Story, ich habe einen Klassiker. Zweite Klasse. Ich glaube, ich saß in dem Abteil dem größten Arschloch der Welt gegenüber, aber auch einem coolen Arschloch. Also cooles Arschloch, sagen wir mal so 13-jähriger Junge, dicker Junge, grossartig, wirklich absolut grossartig, der nämlich einfach während, nachdem der Zug losgefahren ist, hat eine Luftmatratze ausgepackt, ja, aber so eine selbst aufblasende Luftmatratze, was der grösste Beschiss der Welt ist, was der grösste Beschiss der Welt ist, so. Diese ein paar Zentimeter dicken Gummigebilde. Nee, das ist eine Isomatte. Na, eine Isomatte hat ja immer dieselbe Dicke, so. Aber das sind so, die haben so ein Ventil und das machst du dann auf und dann saugen die sich voller Luft auf magische Weise. War die dunkelblau? Die war dunkellila. Ja, dunkellila. Das ist nämlich die eine Isomatte, die ich bei den Pfadfühlen auch immer hatte, die alle hatten, die sich selbst aufgeräumt. Das ist aber keine Isomatte. Ich bin mir sehr sicher, es ist eine Isomatte. Nein, die Isomatte, Iso kommt ja von? Isotonisch. Isos. Von der berühmten Schlacht in der Antike. Nein, von Isolation. Das heißt, die Idee ist ja nur Isolation. Ach, Isolationsdrink. Ja, wohingegen die Luftmatratze ja auch noch Komfort bieten soll. Auf jeden Fall hat er die tatsächlich ausgepackt. Und das ist so, also es gibt viele Dinge, also ich mag ja immer die Momente, in denen Leute was auspacken in dem Zug. Ja, großartig. Und alle sich so denken so, wo führt das jetzt hin? Was kommt jetzt? Und wenn man in 80 Prozent der Fälle denkt, nein, nein, nein. Genau, ja, ja, ja. Aber vor allem, man hat ja nichts zu tun im Zug. Das heißt, alle gucken gerne hin. So, und er packt diese Luftmatratze aus und macht die Schnalle auf und rollt die aus. Und man denkt sich, hey, was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Was ist da vor? Und er breitet die vor? Was ist da vor? Und er breitet die wirklich in dem Abteil über drei Sitze aus, über die, über die, über die, über die, über die, über die, über die, über die, über die, über die, über die, über die, über die, über die, über die, über die, über die, über die, über die, über die, über die, über die, über die, über Arm lehnen. Kann man nicht hochklappen? Nee, kann man nicht hochklappen. Also total strange, wirklich wie so ein geschlängelter Körper, liegt dann da, dick und fett, scheißegal, was alle anderen Menschen der Welt irgendwie wollen oder möchten, ihm scheißegal, er liegt da und wendet seinen Kopf konstant und guckt nach dem Snackwagen. Und das war so ein bisschen living the life. Ja, ja, liegen im Zug, aber Blick auf den Snackwagen. Blick auf den Snackwagen und dann kam der Snackwagen auch und er so, er hatte schon die fünf Euro rausgezogen, schon lange bevor der Snackwagen da war. Und Snackwagen, ich hatte gerne Brezel, holt sich die Brezel und die Brezel wirklich so auf seinem Bauch liegen, schiebt die wie so ein Hamster rein. Warte, ich habe ein Foto gemacht. Ich habe ein Foto gemacht, das ich nicht veröffentlichen werde, aber ich kann es dir zeigen. Grossartig, absolut grossartig. Naja, die Bibelsäule hat eine S-Form. Ja, klar, es passt gar nicht so schlecht. Aber schau dir mal dieses Gesicht an. Und er sieht, dass du ein Foto machst. Nein, tut er nicht. Aber auch mit beiden Händen ist er. Ja, wie so ein Eichhörnchen einfach. Aber mir gefällt, dass die Beine auch so hoch liegen. Es ist nicht so unergonomisch, wie ich dachte. Es hat fast so eine leichte Komfortabilität. Vor allem ist es einfach so die Körperhaltung so, I don't give a shit. Einfach so hier, egal wie er sitzen will. Aber auch mit dem Kopf in Gang. Das heißt, er kann da auch rausgucken dann. Ja, was er gemacht hat, vor allem, der war anscheinend Profi. Der war, und der vor allem... Sowas machst du nicht zum ersten Mal. Nee, sowas machst du nicht zum ersten Mal. Und vor allem, das Krasse war, da saß dann ich mit ihm im Abteil, Abteil sind ja sechs Plätze, ich saß im Abteil und dann kam noch eine andere Frau rein mit Gepäck. Und er meinte dann... Abteil hat immer so was Agatha Christie-artiges. Ja, das stimmt, ja, Mord im Urheilabteil. So gleich stirbt jemand und wir alle könnten es sein, weil wir uns alle schon kennen. Ja, da gibt es so ein Close-Up von jedem und dannsch. Und jeder hat so einen Tick. Und vor allem, der hat dann selbstständig beschlossen, dieses Abteil ist jetzt voll. Mit ihm, einer Frau und mir. Drei Personen. Und dann hat er gesagt, das ist jetzt hier voll. So, und dann hat er Folgendes gemacht. Hat er gesagt? Das hat er auch so angekündigt. Er hat konstant gelabert über irgendeinen Scheiß. Ja, wirklich? Der hat mit der Frau angefangen zu reden, die Frau hat den Fehler gemacht, ihm zu antworten aus Höchlichkeit. Ich habe sofort abgeblockt. Er muss sofort abblocken. Er erzählt, dass er jetzt auf sein Internat fährt und wo er das Wochenende war, ist ihm alles scheißegal. Und das war dieser ICR, und es gibt manche Abteile, die haben keine Tische. Es gibt ja manche Abteile, die haben Tische am Fenster. Und aber immer so, generell hat jeder Platz einen Tisch, nur manche muss man ausklappen. Heißt, Armlehne hochklappen, Tisch rausholen und vor sich klappen. Und das wissen viele nicht, aber es geht um, was er gemacht hat, er hat diesen Tisch auf so eine Art rausgeklappt und gedreht, dass er die Tür blockiert hat. What zum Abteil? Holy shit! Diese Schiebetür, Abteil auf und zu, Schiebetür auf und zu, hat er geschlossen und er hat auf seinem Platz, der direkt ja am Gang war, seinen Armlehne aufgeklappt und so den Tisch hingeklemmt, dass er wirklich so die Tür gesperrt hat. Also so wirklich wie so ein Keil, sodass du von außen die Tür nicht mehr öffnen konntest. Die Fahrkarten bitte! Ey, es war wirklich so, und er so, ne, hier ist jetzt genug Gepäck drin, das Abteil ist voll. Zack, zack, zack, klemmt! Bam! What? Und ich mir nur so, okay, Kollege, ey, ich fahr jetzt schon wirklich lange Zug, aber sowas ist mir noch nie passiert, dass wirklich jemand einfach... Wie lange musst du Zug fahren, um sowas nicht nur zu... Vor allem ist ja auch, man muss es erkennen und man muss dann auch so selbstbewusst handeln, dass man das auch noch macht. Ja, vor allem, was musst du für ein Arschloss sein, dass du nicht nur sagst, mir gehören erst mal per se diese drei Plätze, auf denen ich liege, sondern ich entschweide, dass das Abteil zu ist. Aber human von ihm, weil wenn man sowas weiß, human, dass er euch beiden noch reingelassen hat. Ja. Ich habe auch Danke gesagt. Ja, genau. Weil dann denke ich mir, okay, ihr seid in seinem erlesenen Club, aber vor allem auch ein bisschen gruselig. Also ich finde es immer gruselig, wenn du mit Leuten im Raum bist und dann beschließt jemand, den Raum abzuschliessen. Es ist nie gut. Es endet immer in einem Mord oder einer Vergewaltigung. Ich glaube, was früher so das Tigerknurren war, ist heute das Geräusch des Schlüsselumdrehens. Das ist immer so ein Pfiff und wo ist das gerade passiert? Und auf jeden Fall dann die Frage, was macht man? Einerseits finde ich es gar nicht so schlecht, dass jetzt niemand anders mehr ins Abteil kommt. Was hat die Frau dazu gesagt? Also was du sozifobos Ding dazu gesagt hast. Okay, was hat die Frau, die erwachsene Frau bei euch gesagt? Nichts, gar nichts. Und dann dachte ich mir schon so, nee, jetzt muss ich schon hier was machen, weil das geht nicht. Das ist so irgendwie, irgendjemand muss was sagen, du kannst nicht jetzt diesem kleinen 14-jährigen Jungen jetzt hier seine Tyrannei durchgehen lassen, das geht nicht. Aber erst mal war auch der Zug nicht so voll, nachdem ihr scheiß drauf. Irgendwann kam dann die nächste Haltestelle und es kamen Leute in Gang und die gucken auch so rein, ah, da ist ja noch Platz. Hat jemand versucht, aktiv die Tür zu öffnen? Hat dann versucht, die Tür zu öffnen, ging nicht und war, also was machst du denn dann, auch von draußen, wenn es nicht geht? Ja, aber da sind ja ja, dass Leute darin sitzen. Ja. Du denkst ja, die werden eingesperrt erst mal. Und du denkst ja, also manchmal sind ja diese Schiebetöne wirklich auch zäh und schwer zu ziehen. Und du denkst ja einfach, bin ich zu schwach? Aber irgendwann ziehst du und du denkst dir, also entweder mache ich mich noch weiter zum Deppen und rangele hier rum oder ich gehe. Aber dann kommen gesellschaftliche Trigger in anderen Leuten herum, nee, ich mache schon. Und dann versuchen die dort zu ziehen. Aber da war für mich der Punkt gekommen, wo ich natürlich einfach aufgestanden bin, den Tisch gelöst habe und die Tür aufgemacht habe. Der Ritter der Gesellschaft. Und er wirklich so empört, musste natürlich dann auch seine Liegeposition aufmachen. Und die Person meinte dann so, ist hier Platz? Und ich so, ja, hier ist noch Platz, deute auf die beiden Plätze, wo er liegt, nicht liegt. Und dann hat er auch sein Zeug zusammengepackt und dann saß dann jemand. Und dann hat er aber auch wirklich angekündigt so, nee, jetzt ist hier genug Gepäck, jetzt ist das Abteil voll. Und dann habe ich gesagt, nein, hier sind noch zwei Plätze frei, das Abteil ist noch nicht voll. Und er würde einfach so, nee, nee, nee, nee. Aber da muss ich dann wirklich, also da werde ich dann übermoralisch, wenn ich so ein Arschloch im Abteil habe, wo ich dann denke, ich muss jetzt die Gegenposition beziehen. Ja, da bist du zum anderen Extrem, auch unangenehm. Auch unangenehm, ja. Aber die Mitte zwischen euch ist der perfekte Mensch. So kann man dann handeln. Ja, also ich finde ja, Moral ist da so eine relative Sache. Ich finde, man muss manchmal dann, wenn es nötig ist, eingreifen und dann auch die Gegenposition machen.
Generell habe ich gar nichts dagegen, anderen Leuten
den Platz zu verwehren und auch mal vielleicht
so zwei Sekunden zu lange meinen Rucksack auf dem Platz zu halten.
Da bin ich das größte Arschloch. Aber sobald jemand
ein größeres Arschloch ist, dann musst du die Moralwaage wieder in die
Balance bringen. Ja, dann musst du auf die
andere Richtung bringen. Ah, das ist ja spannend.
Also das war wirklich auch das größte Arschloch.
Der hat auch mit seinem Handy immer dann so
mit vollem Ton
sich irgendwelche Videos angehört. Und der hat sich auch mal
so Bahnhofsvideos angeguckt, von so Bahnhofs
und so ist es Das war wirklich auch das grösste Arschleiter. Der hat auch mit seinem Handy immer dann so mit vollem Ton sich irgendwelche Videos angehört. Und der hat sich auch mal so Bahnhofsvideos angeguckt von so Bahnhofsdurchsagen. Der war anscheinend total im Bahnhofsmindset drin. Das war so sein Ding. Das fand ich wieder sympathisch. Aber der will nicht immer fliegen. Der bestimmt so Wege irgendwie, dass man, während man fliegt, das Fenster runter machen kann. Ja, ja. Der hat also seine Tricks. Aber wie viel Erfindungsreichtum muss er denn dahinter stecken? Dass du plötzlich anfängst, den Tisch umzuklappen und dann mit der Tür zu... Wahnsinn. Vor allem, eigentlich meine schönste, die schönste Situation war, als er schon die Tür blockiert hatte und er legt da Fett und seine Brezenkrümel auf dem Bauch und dann kommt noch mal der Snackwagen durch den Gang. Und er dreht seinen fetten Hals nach dem Snackwagen und ist jetzt in einer Patz-Situation. Er hat sich selbst eingesperrt, aber die Twigs sehen lecker aus. Und er noch mal, und das ist nämlich die Situation, wo dann wirklich die ganzen 80 Kilo in Bewegung kommen und er aufsteht, irgendwie die Blockierung löst und noch mal so schnell es geht die Tür aufmacht, um zu sagen, wie viel kostet Twix? Und das war wirklich, da konnte ich es mir echt nie, also nur schwer verkneifen, weil ich mir wirklich dachte so, du, jetzt hast du dich eingebaut in deine Fettmühle. Und ist es nur lustig, weil er es verdient, dass man über ihn lacht. Genau, er hat natürlich das verdient, er ist ein Arschloch. Ja, genau. Und dann so, oh Twix, und dann holt er sich noch einen Twix. An sich nicht lustig, eher traurig, aber bei so einer Person lustig. Ja, und auch interessant, Moral ändert sich, wie kommen die ja auch dann, der Situation nähert sich. Ja, natürlich, klar, du hast eine Fallhöhe, wenn das einfach jetzt ein armes Kind wäre, das dick ist, ist nicht lustig, aber so blockiert und macht wieder zu, blockiert wieder, was für ein mieses Schwein, ey. Da dachte ich mir wirklich so, Mir gefällt das aber schon. Mir gefällt das schon, wie er die Bahn durchschaut hat. Ja, total. Also der ist halt so ein Pragmatiker. So ein Lifehacker. Pragmatiker, ja. Auch eine Isomatte. Ich finde, man sollte auch, das wäre so ein Ding für mich vielleicht, immer eine Isomatte mitschleppen. Irgendwie, das ist ja auch gut, du bringst ja deine Comfortzone wortwörtlich mit dir mit. Vor allem, das ist also wirklich, der hat ja dann auch, ich habe dann so ein bisschen reingehört, und der hat dann der anderen Frau erklärt, warum er eigentlich immer eine Luftmatratze dabei hat. Und zwar, weil er, und das ist wirklich unglaublich, wenn er in einem Zug ist und es gibt keinen Sitzplatz mehr, legt er sich in den Gang, dann legt er sich auf die Gepäckablage. Ja, aber da saß ich auch schon lange. Oben? Ja, ich saß vier Stunden lang auf der Gepäckablage. Was, da oben? Ja, für mich ist das nicht da oben, für mich ist das, ich setze mich hin und dann sitze ich drauf. Ich habe sehr lange Beine, ich sitze oben dann drauf, ja. Aber da dachte ich mir wirklich so, bitte was? Also der kommt in den Zug, der ist voll, dann packt er seine Luftmatratze aus, schiebt die oben auf die Gepäckab und klettert dann, wuchtet seinen kleinen fetten Körper über die Sitze, klettert er hoch und die sind ja teilweise echt eng und ist dann da eingezwängt, aber also genial, brillant natürlich, man muss sagen, wie alt war der gefühlt? 13, 14, fällt mir schwer. Wie weit ist der, angenommen, der fährt mit 65 mal irgendwann mit der Bahn, was hat er dann für Wege? Wie hat er dann, dann kann er die Bahn fahren, weil er Tricks hat? Ich habe keine Ahnung, der kennt dann irgendwelche speziellen Räume oder legt sich in den Maschinenraum oder hängt sich draußen dran oder so. Er hat Wege, den Snackwagen zu überfallen oder so. Wahnsinn. Ich meine, das war wirklich so. Er kriegt so Steine, so Kieselsteine, steut er dann rein. Und der Snackwagen geht in den Steuern und fällt um. Es ist ein Naturtalent einfach. Ich versuche ja auch manchmal so hier und da. Ich habe, glaube ich, einen anderen moralischen Standard. Aber ich versuche es ja auch zum Beispiel, bin ich jetzt darauf umgestiegen, wenn ich mir einen Platz reserviere, nicht in der Mitte des Wagens, sondern entweder am Anfang des Wagens oder am Ende des Wagens. Warum? Okay, dann buchst du aber wirklich monatelang vorher, vor der Reise. Nö, in der Woche davor, das geht schon. Und ich meine, ich habe ja immer dieselben Fahrten. Ich fahre immer nach Hamburg und wieder zurück. Das sind immer dieselben Fahrten, weil ich habe nämlich gelernt, ich will nicht, dass niemand neben mir sitzt. Das heißt, Leute steigen ein und gehen dann in den Wagen und gucken sich um. Und sobald sie den Wagen betreten, sind ihre Ansprüche noch sehr hoch. Sie sagen, ich will einen Zweierplatz für mich. Heißt, sie gehen in die Mitte und hoffen, dass ein Zweierplatz auftaucht. Richtig, das heißt, sie ignorieren die freien Plätze am Anfang. Aber so weiter sie in die Mitte kommen, desto mehr sinken die Ansprüche. Und sobald sie so ungefähr ein Drittel passiert haben, dann nehmen sie auch ein, wo schon jemand sitzt und sagen, ist er noch frei. Das heißt, die füllen sich auf von der Mitte nach außen. Das heißt, wenn du am Anfang oder am Ende des Wagens sitzt, hast du am längsten einen Platz für dich alleine. Wenn du aber ganz am Rand sitzt, erwischst du oft die einen Stationen Fahrer, die nur mal kurz rein schlug. Ja, aber sind die so schlimm, die mal mitzunehmen? Ist ganz interessant, aber das sind oft die Gesprächigen, weil wer so kurz nur Zug fährt, der macht das häufiger, der hat das so drin im Blut und dann fängt man schon an mit Leuten zu sprechen und so. Das sind oft die Gesprächigen. Weil wer so kurz nur Zug fährt, der macht das häufiger. Der hat das so drin im Blut. Und dann fängt man schon an, mit Leuten zu sprechen. Das sind oft die Schnacker. Aber ideal ist natürlich so drei Plätze in den Zug rein. Ja, genau. Ich meine, es gibt ja noch eine ganz eigene Mathematik, was die Fensterzuweisung angeht. Wo man den Block hat zwischen den Fenstern und gar nichts sieht, wo ein gutes Fenster ist. Da habe ich mittlerweile den Code geknackt, ich möchte ihn aber ehrlich gesagt nicht öffentlich machen. Aber ich kenne ihn, glaube ich, der hast du auch schon mal öffentlich gemacht, glaube ich. Guck mal den alten Folgen. Ich finde immer interessant, ich will ja auch nicht, dass jemand neben mir sitzt. Ich hoffe immer, den Platz zu erwischen, wo der neben mir zwar reserviert, aber nicht kommt. Das ist natürlich die Königsdisziplin. Oder du reservierst selbst den Platz daneben. Das kostet aber fünf Euro. Das will ich ja auch nicht. Ich will ja natürlich maximal wenig Lebensqualität opfern dafür. Für maximale Lebensqualität. Und deswegen überlege ich ganz häufig, nehme ich den Platz, wenn er schon reserviert ist, nehme ich dann den Platz, den Zweierplatz, wo schon einer weg ist, oder nehme ich den, wo der andere noch frei ist? In der Hoffnung, dass der andere reserviert hat, aber nicht kommt, weil er schon zu lange im Voraus reserviert hat. Dann kann es oft dazu kommen, dass der gar nicht erst auftaucht, der Platz aber reserviert ist und sich niemand hinsetzen kann, weil du die ganze Zeit draufzeichnen kannst und sagen, es ist reserviert. Das würdest du auch machen. Wenn sich da jemand hinsetzen möchte, sagst du, nee, der ist noch reserviert, zwar nicht von mir, aber ich sage dann häufig, nee, der ist gerade im Bordbistro. Oh, Steff, das ist ein Schritt zu weit für mich. Das ist perfide. Und es geht auch oft daneben, wenn dann jemand sagt, ja, dann bleibe ich immer so lange hier sitzen. Dann kann ich ja wieder aufstehen, wenn der kommt. Und dann die Frage, kommt der noch vom Bordbistro und man sagt, der ist wahrscheinlich dann auch ausgestiegen. Und du, ich muss nur kurz auf die Toilette und springst aus dem Fenster einfach. Ja, man dann sagt so, nee, der ist bestimmt ausgestiegen, ja, aber sein Koffer ist doch noch über dir, was du dann als sein Koffer ausgegeben hast. Dann sagt er, oh, genau, hat er hier seinen Koffer verlassen. Dann wird die Bombenentschärfung gerufen, weil man denkt, er hat den Koffer zurückgelassen. Dann ziehen sie den Studio-Hamburg-Preis
aus deinem Koffer.
Stefan Tietze, sind das nicht Sie?
Und dann geht alles runter und drüber.
Und man sagt sich, gut, dann lieber neben jemandem sitzen.
Dann einfach mal schön ladet der Rihanna.
Aber ich bin auch so ein Improver.
Ich versuche Dinge zu improven.
Und ich versuche auch Dinge herauszufinden.
Und ich bin jetzt, ich habe einen Durchbruch.
Warum nimmst du denn den Kopfhörer ab? Das hat mich jetzt sehr verwirrt.
Kein Bock mehr. Wir hören uns nicht jetzt nicht über Kopfhörer. Und plötzlich nimmt er einfach den Kopfhörer ab und gibt einen Scheiss draus.
Ne, meine Ohren tun ein bisschen weh. Ja, meine auch. Das ist ein ganz komischer Ton heute.
Lass uns mal den FKK-Teil, die letzten zehn Minuten ins FKK-Teil.
Oh, komm. Ziehen uns aus. Okay. Okay. Oh, na ja. Das klingt jetzt. Das ist ein bisschen unangenehm, ne? Ja. Okay, ich bin mal gespannt, was sich ändert. Naja, wir haben gesagt, wir würden uns wahrscheinlich erst richtig vertrauen, und das ist ein richtig gutes Team, wenn wir uns mal nachts sehen.
Ja.
Und?
Ich weiß nicht, ich fühle mich ein bisschen...
So, gut, also, du hast einen Durchbruch gemacht?
Also, ich habe einen Durchbruch, in dem ich etwas herausgefunden habe, etwa eine gesellschaftliche Konvention, die ich nie ganz verstanden habe, nämlich die gesellschaftliche Konvention namens Gute Nacht sagen, habe ich nie ganz verstanden. Warum sagt man das? Warum verabschiedet man sich von Menschen, mit denen man die Nacht verbringt? Warum sagt man Tschaui bis morgen und liegt dann noch zehn Stunden nebeneinander, um dann aufzustehen und sich wieder begrüssen zu müssen? Das schloss ich mir nicht. Also entweder kommt es aus der Zeit, in der Menschen noch nicht wussten, wie Schlaf funktioniert und dachten, sie sterben jetzt einfach. Und dachten sich so, war schön mit dir, tschau. Und dann nächster Tag so, ja, okay. So, und ich habe aber jetzt herausgefunden, warum man das macht. Weil ich habe dann versucht, okay, ich bin radikal, ich bin Pionier, ich versuche es mal einfach, sage nicht gute Nacht. Führt dann dazu, dass man spricht mit seinem Bettpartner, spricht, irgendwann aufhört zu sprechen und acht Stunden lang awkward nebeneinander liegt. Ja, ja, ja. Und dann am nächsten Morgen aufsteht und sagt, ja, das ist aber unangenehm, weil man wirklich acht Stunden lang einfach das Gespräch unterbrochen hat. Jetzt könnte man direkt wieder anfangen, das Gespräch weiterzuführen, was man am Vortag begonnen hat, theoretisch. Aber es ist einfach nur sehr unangenehm. Also macht das nicht. Und deswegen schließe ich schon. Ich glaube, der einzige Grund, warum man Gute Nacht sagt, ist, damit danach keine unangenehme Pause. Ja, damit man einen Abschluss hat. Man moderiert gewissermaßen den Tag ab. Ja. So, das war's. Vom Mittwoch macht's gut. Vielen Dank an dich, vielen Dank an Alexa, mach das Licht im Schlafzimmer aus, vielen Dank.
Es ist aber manchmal echt schwer, das Timing für Gute Nacht zu treffen, weil man kann ja sein, dass man sich unterhält und dann hört man auf zu reden und dann vergehen so zehn Minuten und man ist so halb eingeschlafen und denkt sich, soll ich jetzt noch, soll ich jetzt noch, weil so ganz lose ist Gute Nacht auch merkwürdig.
Schatz, hey, hey, bitte wach, hey, hey, Gute Nacht ganz lose ist Gute Nacht auch merkwürdig. Hey, hey, hey, bist du wach?
Hey, hey, Gute Nacht, ich will Gute Nacht sagen.
Weil es ist schon so, naja, dann habe ich dem gesagt, dass ich jetzt eigentlich das nicht mehr machen will.
Okay, Gute Nacht, so, dann ist es ein Abschluss.
Aber wenn du einfach Stille hast für zehn Minuten und dann so aus dem Nichts,ute Nacht, dann ist es so ein bisschen Moment mal, worauf dann schwingt mehr mit. Trotzdem wichtig. Falsch, man soll das im Gespräch einbetten so, ich muss auch morgen früh raus, gute Nacht. Man muss so ein bisschen mal den Tag abmoderieren, trotzdem ist gute Nacht wichtig, sonst unangenehme Pause für acht Stunden. Es hat natürlich auch interessante sexuelle Implikationen. Es ist ja manchmal so dieses, man liegt zusammen im Bett und man weiß nicht, geht da noch was. Und dann ist natürlich so ein, Gute Nacht, auch so ein Schlag ins... Dann schlafe ich jetzt. Ja, entweder das oder so ein Versuchserst gar nicht. Oder es ist so ein, also wenn man während dem Rumknutschen Gute Nacht sagt, ist es natürlich auch eine Möglichkeit. Ja, ja. Gute Nacht, so. Es ist natürlich aber auch, kann natürlich auch passiv-aggressiv sein. Dann schließt so die Tür leicht. Genau, ja, ja. Langsam macht man sie zu, kommt da noch was, kommt da noch was? Es kann aber natürlich auch so ein, offensichtlich kriegst du es nicht auf die Reihe, dann jetzt gute Nacht, so ein passiv-aggressives Sein. Also ich glaube, das ist auch wichtig, da klare Ansagen zu machen. Ich finde es sehr interessant. Gut, da bin ich was Sexuelles. Weil ich habe dann oft schreibe ich mit Leuten abends noch, habe mein Handy in der Hand und schreibe dann halt noch mit dem Handy. Und dann schreibt man mit einem Kumpel vielleicht. Und irgendwann kommt man dann zu dem Punkt, wo der Kumpel mir geschrieben hat, ja, ich muss jetzt ins Bett. Und man schreibt ihm guteute Nacht und dann schreibt er Gute Nacht. Und plötzlich hat es so was ganz Sexuelles. Man hat nur am falschen Zeitpunkt des Tages geschrieben. Sonst wäre das ja nie, es wäre eine ganz normale, kommst du morgen Basketball spielen, ja, komm, wir gehen mal Basketball spielen, okay, machen wir so. Und dann beginnt man die Kommission an den nächsten Punkt. Sobald man aber sagt, ja, ich muss jetzt los, ich muss jetzt splafen, und der andere sagt, gute Nacht, ja, gute Nacht, ist man so, als ob man jetzt mit ihm, man geht mit ihm virtuell jetzt ins Bett. Ja, ja, es stimmt, gute Nacht ist die intimste der Verabschiedungsformeln und es ist manchmal nicht leicht zu finden, ab wann man das schreibt mit jemandem, so dieses, wenn man abends schreibt und man beendet und so, gute Nacht, also sowas wie schönes Wochenende ist völlig unverfänglich. Wenn Menschen, die ich das erste Mal sehe, Freitag, sage ich schönes Wochenende. Wohingegen gute Nacht. Ist sogar sehr asexuell. Es ist maximal asexuell. Man nennt mich antisexuell. Ja. Weil wenn du eine Partnerin sagst, schönes Wochenende, dann geht da nichts. Ja, nicht. Dann geht bis Montag gar nichts. Oder ich meine, guten Morgen kann man auch am Kiosk sagen, aber gute Nacht. Schlafen ist halt, das sagt man halt dann schon eher im tiefsten Kreis. Ja, und nach guter Nacht folgt oft Schlafgut. Und dann, wenn man dann dem Kumpel schreibt, Schlafgut, träum was Süsses zum Beispiel. Don't let the bad bugs bite. Don't let the bad bugs bite. Schlafgut, träum was Schönes. Träum was Schönes. Das ist schon komisch. Dann wird es unnötig sexuell. These, die wirklich interessanten Sachen sagt man nach Gute Nacht. Beispiel, Übernachten beim Kumpel oder Matratzenlager oder Klassenfahrt, Gute Nacht, Gute Nacht, Gute Nacht. Hey, hey, die Nina, hey, die hat doch heute diesen Rock an.
Ja, okay, gute Nacht.
Aber dann kam keine Gute Nacht mehr.
Das stimmt.
Ja, schon dann kam keine Gute Nacht mehr.
Da kam nie mehr Gute Nacht, weil der Tag war abmoderiert,
und man ist jetzt in so einem, so komisch in Nirvana, in so einer Zwischenwelt.
Es ist so wie die Szene nach dem Abspann.
So, man kommt noch was, und dann ... Das ist der Epilog des Tages. Und der hat ja auch keinen Abspann mehr. Nee, genau. Marvel-Filme haben auch am Ende dann keinen Abspann mehr. Genau. So, und das heißt, genau, und dann war, gute Nacht, gute Nacht, dann geht das Licht aus, der offizielle Tag war vorbei und dann, hey, hey, was geht, hey, wie geht's dir gerade so, ist das eine coole Fahrt, oder? Ja, gut. Aber dann kam er immer ein bisschen aufgeregt, immer dieses, hey, Leute, hey, ich glaube, die Dinosaurier hatten Federn, Stefan, halt die Fresse, wir reden können immer nie, was geht mit Tina. Was glaubt ihr, ist Ninas Lieblingsdino? Ach, halt die... Einer schläft immer schon.
Wollen wir dem was ins Gesicht malen?
Nee, nee, nee, oder?
Und dann oft diese Gespräche, die unkreativsten Nagelschläfer.
Ich finde, Tina ist echt.
Ja, und was, was wolltest du sagen gerade?
Sorry, du wolltest gerade was sagen.
Du hast Hey gesagt, was wolltest du gerade sagen?
Ja, und dann diese Gespräche. Was, was wolltest du sagen gerade? Sorry, du wolltest gerade was sagen. Du hast gerade Hey gesagt, was wolltest du gerade sagen?
Ja, und dann diese Gespräche enden immer mit, ja gut, dann unterhalte sie heute, hey, schläfst du schon?
Was, Jochen schläft schon, hey, und diese Gespräche enden immer, dass einer noch Hey ins Nichts ruft.
Ja, genau, und du willst nicht der Depp sein, der als letztes Hey sagt.
Jochen schwebt schon. Welcher Jochen war in eurem Alter?
Welcher Jochen war mit euch damals unterwegs?
Tatsächlich niemand, aber ist das so ein ungewöhnlicher Name, Jochen?
Für unser Alter? Jochen?
Das fand ich schon sehr.
Ist zu alt, aber.
Welcher Jochen hat bei euch im Zimmer geschlafen?
Zu alt meinst du?
Ja, Jochen gleich Ü50.
U gleich 50. Ü gleich ÜG 50. Ja. Machen wir das Podcast-Ufe-Ferienlager mal? Einfach so in der Halle, jeder kriegt eine Matratze und dann so 200 Leute in einer Halle. Ach so, ich darf nur wir beide. Lass mal Camp gehen. Alter, Alter. Aber du musst mal Camp gehen. Ja, schön im Wald. Ich würde mal gerne im Wald campen. Dann nehmen Sie diese alte Kamera mit, die man so aus Lost and Found Footage Film kennt, wo man dann diesen Camcorder, wo man diese Vaterklappe aufmachen kann, wo man dann auch diese Vaterklappe und die Vater Schlaufe hat, wo man die Hand reinschieben kann und dann gut filmen kann. Ja. Ja, das machen wir, dann machen wir so einen Film.
Oder machen wir so ein Lagerfeuer.
Könntest du das?
Nee.
Ich würde es aber erst versuchen, mit dem Stock uns für anderen stöcken,
und dann würde ich versuchen, so zu reiben, bis Feuer entsteht.
Dann würde ich aufgeben, frustriert, und dann sagen, hey, es ist aber schnell dunkel geworden.
Hey, ist das ein Bär?
Ich glaube nicht, ist die Bienen da? Nein, die Bienen, die Bienen sind wieder da. Was machen Bienen in der Nacht? Schlafen. Ernsthaft? Ja, und das war aus von der Biologie schon. Ja, das war... Ja, vor allem, ich war neulich in dem Gartencenter, und dann gab es da neben dem ganzen Gartencenter-Kram Pflanzen, Vogelhäuschen, Grills, gab's Insektenhotels.
Und dann sah man aber, überall war bei Gartendünger, war die Reihe leer, da wurden schon viele Sachen genommen, viele Produkte waren schon weg, bei dem Fischfutter war schon viel weg.
Insektenhotels und Wespenhotels, komischerweise noch alle da.
Und ich frage, habt ihr vor, die jemals zu verkaufen?
Ja.
Spart euch diesen Regal. Hey, holt Tiere, die niemand mag, in euren Garten. In euren Garten. Nope. Hier, Wespenhotels. Auf keinen Fall. Und dann gab es auch so ein Insektenhotel mit so ganz grossen Löchern, wo man sich sagt, ich will gar nicht wissen, was da drin wohnt. So kleine, süße Löcher, so, aber wenn die so Fingerdaumendick werden. Ja, so Hornessen, Hornissennest,. Hornesse. Hornessen-Nister. Und dann kann man sich wirklich so ein Bienenvolk bei sich halten. Was wiederum ganz cool ist für Honig. I get the idea. Aber Wespenhotels? Naja, oder es ist halt dann eher so ein Serienmörderhotel. Es gab doch so einen Serienmörder, der hat ein Hotel, nur um Leute darin umzubringen. Nee, äh, ne. Vouilleur. Jemand, der die angeguckt hat. Ach, das auch. Ich glaube, das ist was anderes. Ich meine aber das. Ja, ich meine aber was anderes. Ja, dann mein halt was anderes. Dann kann man sich halt ein Wespenhotel. Weil ein Wespenhotel ist ein Stück Holz, wo du Löcher reinbohrst. Ja, Hotel. Das muss man echt nicht kaufen. Ja, aber auch so eine Rezeption, so eine kleine. Und dann musst du dem Schlüssel du dem Schlüssel geben, und dann können Sie bitte kurz noch Ihr Geburtstag und Ihr Adresse eintreten. Und dann so Bewertungen abgeben, so... Zahlen Sie mit Kreditkarte. Verschiedene Wespen gegen drei von fünf Sternen. Wo ist das WLAN-Passwort? Das ist so merkwürdig, das ist dasselbe Tier. Also das ist wie so eine Boyband. Also es gibt den Süssen, die Biene. Nee, es sind wie Pokémon Weiterentwicklungen. Nee, aber die ändern sich ja nicht im Charakter. Honigbiene, Honigbiene, na bitte was? Na ja, na ja. Honigbiene, Wespe, Hornisse sind ja offensichtlich Pokémon-Entwicklungen. Naja, aber es gibt so das Arschloch, die Hornisse, es gibt so den Süssen, die Biene, es gibt so den bisschen Dümlichen, die Wespe. Dümlich! Es ist eine Boyband. Ja klar, Wespen spielen, die fiegen noch ständig in diese Brutzelteile rein. Und ich glaube auch, dass Bienen dumm sind, weil sonst würden die ja nicht aussterben. Erfahrungsgemäß sterben, staubt die ja nicht aus. Na, Bienen sind die süssen, die sind pummelig, irgendwie ein bisschen süss. Hummeln sind pummelig. Und dann gibt es auch so diese Mimikrie-Viecher, die gar nichts können, nur so aussehen. Das sind halt so ein bisschen der oberflächliche Kunde. Ja, und das sind den dicken, pummeligen Bruder, die Hummel. Die nicht? Ja, die Hummel, genau, Hummel ist so ein bisschen das Klösschen. Und niemand weiß, kannst du stechen, kannst du liegen? Ey, die Theorie ist perfekt, das ist eine Boyband, das ist einfach wirklich so ein Team, die zusammen funktionieren können. Ey, hundertprozentig, man könnte eine Kinderserie machen, wie nennt man diese Art von Tieren, Fliegeninsekten, man könnte eine Kinderserie machen, schwarz-gelbe Fliegeninsekte, nur mit diesen verschiedenen Vertretern, die kämpfen dann so wie bei Avatar, der eine ist aus der Feuerfraktion, der andere aus der Wasserfraktion, und der eine ist der König der Hummeln, König der Bienen, und dann König Bremsen und die machen zusammen was. So Prinzessinnen oder so was.
Gab es bei Bienemaja in der Welt der Bienemaja-Wespen?
Auf jeden Fall gab es Hornissen.
Und einmal haben die fast eine andere Biene geschnochen.
Das weiß ich noch, glaube ich.
Gibt es solche Menschen in der Bienemaja-Welt?
In der Mine-Baja?
Barney-Maja? Gibt es da Menschen?
Nein, ich glaube nicht. So schwierig zu animieren. Das ist der Grund. Gibt's den Mond in Biene Meier? Hat man jemals Jupiter gesehen bei Biene Meier? Das ist die nächste empörte Fanmail. Gibt's den Jupiter bei Biene Meier? Da schreiben wir jetzt direkt eine E-Mail an ZDF oder sowas. Wo ist der Jupiter? Ich habe noch nie den Himmelsgestirn des Jupiters gesehen in ihrer ach so tollen Serie. Halt die Fresse. Oh, Alexander Gerst ist ins Allgefliehen. Ja, hatten wir letztens erst im Podcast-Ufo. Jetzt ist er im All. Ich bin gespannt. Ich habe wirklich fast eine Träne verdrückt, als ich den gesehen habe. Wirklich? Mir war das völlig egal. Nee ist ein Job. Lustigerweise, ich verstehe nicht, manche Sachen berühren mich. Und ich bin einer der gefühltesten Menschen, die ich kenne. Mir ist alles scheißegal. Aber bei Filmen und bei Astronauten könnte ich die ganze Zeit weinen. Und bei Gratzeis. Und bei Gratzeis. Nee, aber dann ist ja jetzt allgeflogen. Da war irgendwann noch so ein kleiner weisser Punkt, ein leuchtender Punkt. Und alle Welt haben geschrieben, viel Glück, viel Erfolg, Astro Alex. Auch Astro Alex. Aber wie groß ist die Mannschaft? Drei. Drei Leute. Und das ist auch so toll. Eine Amerikanerin, ein Russe und ein Deutscher. Und so viele politische Differenzen. Und alle drei fliegen ins All. In dieser kleinen Rakete müssen zwei Tage lang durchs Weltall fliegen, in dieser kleinen Sojus-Kapsel und landen dann auf der ISS. Und da trennen die sich dann. Und der Russe geht ins russische Abteil, der Deutsche geht ins europäische Abteil, und der amerikanische geht ins amerikanische Abteil. Und die sehen sich nie. Die sehen sich zum Abendessen. Wäre das eine Sitcom, so eine ISS-WG? Ja, finde ich mehr gut. Aber es ist sau schwierig zu drehen. Also, du musst ja dann unter Wasser drehen oder so, wegen der Schwerkraft. Ja, du musst ja beim Parabelflügen, musst du, also je Tag ein, 30 Sekunden Drehzeit. Auf Sat1 Gold, die Astrow-WG, ey Leute, wir sind instant pleite, wir könnten 40 Sekunden produzieren. Wir haben 30 Jahre gebraucht, um fünf Minuten Astrow-WG zu erzählen, wegen Parabelflug. Gleich nach Schillerstrasse, die Astrow-G. Wir hatten jeden Tag 30 Sekunden lang Zeit zu drehen. Und am Wochenenden gibt es keine Parabelflüge. Wir haben 30 Jahre gebraucht. Oh Mann. Das dann aber als Animationsserie. Ja, das ist eine Animationsserie. Und es gibt den Wetter nicht. Wir setzen mal Tarkan und Miguel dran,
vielleicht kriegen wir es ja zumindest ein lustiges GIF.
Genau. Leute,
apropos abheben.
Das war es mal wieder eine schöne Woche,
wünsche ich euch. Vielen Dank an Sören für das Intro
und ansonsten vielen Dank an alle, die weiterhin
Intros einschicken. Wir haben schon eine Menge, aber wir freuen uns
über alle weiteren, die immer noch kommen. Ja? Vielen Dank
und habt eine schöne Woche, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Habt eine schöne Woche, wie immer ab, ciao! Liebe Grüße an Alexander,
ciao!